bernie sanders a few days ago the day
the day before the election bernie
sanders is he's he's doing a zoom call
with the quad with the squad
squad the four ladies yeah yeah there he
is
yeah and you know they look at him like
a god by the way
all of us are working very hard to make
that happen but we understand
that electing biden is not the end-all
it is the beginning
okay and i think as the result of the
work
that all of you have done biden's
proposals
in this campaign are a lot stronger than
they were in the primary alexandria
i was on the climate change task force
did a great job
uh and his proposals are stronger do
they go as far as
we would want no they don't okay
biden unlike trump does not conceive of
himself as a dictator that means
you have your job in the house i've got
my job with
others in the senate and we're not
giving up on our agenda for example one
area
you know biden wants to expand health
care that's good wants the lower
prescription drug costs
that's great wants the double funding
for community health centers
very important but you know when i know
that at the end of the day
the only way that we're going to provide
quality care to every man woman and
child
in an affordable way is through medicare
for all
and we ain't giving up on that struggle
well all right we're going to introduce
medicare for all believe me we are and
we have because of
all of your efforts and the efforts of
greatness
nurses and others throughout the country
we've got a majority of the people who
support us
so thank you for that green new deal we
ain't giving up on that we know
my god i mean every day positive the
horrors going on
yeah because he can go on and on and on
but you notice that that's a screen full
of
people in congress house of
representatives senators
i mean look biden can come in on day one
and say
i am my own man i'm going to be choosing
my own
cabinet and there will be no members of
the u.s house of congress
uh who are going to be members of my
cabinet moving on to the next thing
and do you think he's going to do that i
think it's
you know jamie dimon wrote some very uh
jamie dimon alluded to that in some
public comments that he made recently
i bring up jamie dimon because he runs
the largest bank in the country
and if you're going to have a successful
administration you might want to have
the biggest banks on board with you
they might be more important so again
if he crafts a cabinet that is more
reaganesque
and less left then i think he will have
a much
easier task on his hands plus the fact
that nancy pelosi has lost seats
six of them so the the the democratic
stronghold in the house is not as strong
as it was
so uh you know there are three seats
left one seat went
um to the democrats last night in in the
senate
so uh that that was a bit of a surprise
so now you're down to three seats it
still
looks like republicans are going to
retain control of the senate and that is
a harder grasp
than when you've got a house that can
float either way because there's so many
more moving
people moving parts but she has lost
some control
of that house it's it's up to joe biden
to choose a cabinet that can work with
all of them
you